shortly before 1 o'clock on Wednesday
morning an inferno broke out in a tower
block in West London
[Music]
at least 58 people were killed in the
fire at Grenville tower that number is
expected to rise
that night witnessed scenes of
unimaginable horror
it's quite high up like just above the
middle and she was screaming I've got a
baby please help me go I can't go I'm
trapped I need to save my baby as well
as those of astonishing bravery as I was
buried down downstairs you had
firefighters going up the stairs three
firefighters going up the stairs the
Prime Minister has finally announced a
full public inquiry and today the
Chancellor's shock revelation that the
cladding around the building may have
been banned we need to know what
happened we need to know have an
explanation of this we owe that to the
families to the people who have lost
loved ones friends and the homes in
which they lived
now with protests on the streets of the
government's response there is growing
evidence this tragedy is turning into a
criminal and political scandal
[Music]
these were the scenes in Britain's
richest Bharath last Friday evening an
angry mob storming kensington town hall
demanding answers and an increasingly
beleaguered Prime Minister chased out of
the area with cries of murderer ringing
in the streets the build-up to these
extraordinary scenes started five days
ago at six minutes to one on the morning
of Wednesday the 14th of June the London
Fire Brigade received a 999 call it
reported a fire had broken out in a
block of flats in Latimer Road West
London
the emergency services arrived six
minutes later the flames were already
beginning to spread residents were
trapped on the upper floors this footage
is filmed by a woman who lived on one of
the top floors of Grenville tower
her name is Rania Ibrahim a mother of
two her front door is the only
protection from the acrid smoke
billowing along the corridors
[Music]
the footage was posted on Facebook at
1:40 a.m. as the emergency services
arrived they started communicating by
loudspeaker she says the police are
telling us to get out the whole building
is on fire and we're on the floor above
how are we going to get out Rania and
her two children are among those who are
officially listed as missing
within 20 minutes of the alarm being
raised 40 fire engines arrived at the
Lancaster West Estate but the
firefighters were already facing an
impossible task their ladders and hoses
could only reach the 12th floor in less
than 20 minutes the inferno was blazing
on all 23 stories yes residents and
neighbors below could only watch and
listen powerless to help
[Music]
some residents on the lower floors
managed to escape one eyewitness claimed
he knew how the fire started
it's by chance that we had a knock and
the guy who not so happens to be the guy
whose house was the course of the whole
thing this is rich he explained to us as
he came down after his son was outside
the building he explained to us that he
was true to his rage which exploded
there's a law on a fourth floor in
Houston the 16th and you think everyone
inside the block is evacuated no no how
do you know how do we know cause device
very extremely quick and people on
left-hand side of the building was
criminal help us sticking outside the
window people waving phones for you
notice for infeasibility there was
there's so much smoke coming around
there now
as the fire continued to rage more
eyewitnesses came forward when I lived
that a five minute walk away and we
could hear people screaming help me help
me and flashing their phone lights to
let people know that they were there
we've just been asked to bring up water
to the people that have come out there
and we they let food accordance to green
up loads of bottles of water
the enormity of the tragedy meant more
than a hundred extra police officers
were quickly drafted in and more than 20
ambulance crews raced to the tower to
treat casualties and ferry the seriously
injured to nearby hospitals
[Music]
by first light the next morning there
was little doubt this was one of
Britain's worst fires in modern times a
23-story residential block with 124
homes now little more than the blackened
smoldering shell
[Music]
gradually the survivors of Grenville
tower terrified and exhausted emerged to
tell their horrific stories
I wasn't woken up by the alarms at all
they were very very quietly lunch I was
in bed I was on the verge of falling
asleep and I smelled plastic I've got up
of leaks around the flat check their
plugs
everything was okay I went to the
kitchen to smoke a cigarette I've opened
a window and I heard some woman saying
it's getting bigger it's getting bigger
so I've gone out to the hallway I've
looked for this fire oh I see smoke
everywhere I've opened the door and the
neighbors would end and people screaming
the firemen didn't get down the stairs
so I grabbed a little girl grab my
girlfriend ran out of the house I heard
a lot of screams and I could see Africa
outside I was looking up and I could see
people bent on the windows and it was
fire all around him who surrenders
[Music]
there's a lot of people on the upper
floors flashing their torch lights and
the most upsetting thing about it all
was
you could you could make out there was a
couple of young kids with flashlights
waving at people to try and help them
you can hear a lot of screaming saying
help me please please please and it's
just really emotional and sad to hear
[Music]
so people who the 14th row crying people
from the 16th floor my neighbor his aunt
was struggling I told him where's your
dad because I know his dad and he said
to me he's in doors he can't walk a
certain let's go in when we went try to
get in the Smoky's know where you can
get me I was going through the floor the
fire brigade we had their oxygen we
never had the oxygen so I just have to
leave
[Music]
yet for all the tales of horror at
Grenville tower there was still praise
for the remarkable courage of the
emergency services as I was going
downstairs you had three firefighters
going up the stairs but an MBA set saw
them basically going up trying to get
rescue as many people as they possibly
did as they were going up I did ask them
if you want me to knock on people's
doors to try and help in any way which I
possibly could they just said to me for
your own safety and later
heart-wrenching testimony from the
firefighters themselves we had a little
boy who came downstairs with it with his
mother who was in a very bad way talking
about five years old and we asked is
anyone else in that flat and he's thrown
on his own he says my brother but he's
dead
the whole building was completely
engulfed in flames
we were all inside that building and a
lot of times the crews that the ones
that were there initially in the crews
ahead of me were upstairs going into
floors without any water simply just
looking around and just trying to do
their best banging on doors or kicking
in doors and trying to get people out
in the first of many news conferences
that day the most senior fire officer in
London confirmed the enormity of the
disaster this is a unprecedented
incident in my 29 years of being a
firefighter I have never ever seen
anything of this scale our first fire
engines were unseen in under six minutes
crews wearing breathing apparatus and
extended duration breathing apparatus
have been working in extremely
challenging and very difficult
conditions to rescue people and to bring
this major fire under control at this
time I am very sad to confirm that there
have been a number of fatalities
[Music]
officially there were now multiple
deaths and that meant many questions
how come a fire that appears to have
started in a fourth floor flat at
engulfed an entire building in less than
20 minutes
in the early hours of Wednesday morning
a fire which residents say started in
the fourth floor flat of Grenville Tower
in West London that destroyed the entire
building the whole block is gone
the flames had spread through the
structure creating an inferno that was
impossible for the emergency services to
tackle
eyewitnesses to the tragedy spoke of
unimaginable horror
there's people rolling down the sheets
and trying to make rules to to get down
obviously they must have been trapped
and they couldn't get out and there was
banging on the windows screaming
flashing lights to try and get their
attention there was the fire going to
trying to put lighters up a different
cake different parts of the building
it was quite high up like just above the
middle and she was screaming I've got a
baby please help me Dow I can't get out
I'm trapped I need to save my baby I
don't see a few people John people were
jumping and I think at that point it was
you leave a jump in trying to save your
life you might break a few bones or get
engulfed in that flame I saw two people
jump from the right hand side [ __ ] I
think they were either froth from 10 to
15 I couldn't tell you which broad I
couldn't tell you if they were adult so
I'm going to tell you if they were kids
or teenagers all I could see is two
people flinging themselves off the thing
people telling me other people doing it
on the other on the other side as well
there's just one staircase one in one
answer if you can't get to them
staircase you are not getting out that
building there's only one way out that
Gordon unless the job
[Music]
throughout the morning the London Fire
Brigade continued to tackle the blaze
although the chances of finding any
survivors were receding their work
glimmers of hope a man is seen standing
to the left of the picture peering out
of his flat while three storeys above
the building burns we don't know his
fate
at the same time anxious relatives spoke
of their desperate calls to loved ones
in the tower 10-15 minute later we
phoned him back and I said where is your
husband she said he's still talking and
they said they're coming to us and I
said what happened she said the last
thing she said smoke is coming heavily
through the door into the flat that was
the last time
I pray to God that they're okay the fire
did go and spread to that part of the
building there positive early and I know
that they I was told from people who had
managed to contact them that they had
moved to the flats next door but we
asked around on old people the services
in the authorities are still trying to
gather information have gone to several
of the rescue centers that have been set
up and asked and given names that we've
had nothing so far I know it takes a
while just praying to God that they're
all right with so much confusion
surrounding the fate of those in the
building relatives of the missing began
to organize their own searches Corrine
Mazzilli began to look for his uncle
he'd last heard from Hisham ramen at
3:00 a.m. on the day of with little
information to go on
kerim did everything he possibly could
to find his uncle including stopping
passing strangers would you be able to
put up some oh [ __ ] us thank you very
much thank you
they're not letting anybody in the
hospital as he walked the streets he
helped coordinate the efforts of other
family members as they too searched the
hospital's so encore basically said that
he's gone to Chelsea immersiveness the
hospital he's been in there they've
identified all of the people that have
come from the gruntal towers and my
uncle wasn't one of them
so he's now making his way to the next
hospital he said centenary hospital
she's gonna go there next and see what
happens although he spent the rest of
the day looking games desperate search
was fruitless as news of the disaster
spread donations began to pour in from
all over the capital food water clothing
everyday items we all take for granted
that now become essentials for those
who'd lost everything in the fire it was
a heartening display of solidarity from
Londoners of every race creed class and
color why have you decided to come all
the way across London tell people out
presuming you've never met me to be
honest it's Ramadan right now so
the month of giving to people sub and
since now this happened it was a good
thing to do to help people out basically
what's in your bag do you - they taught
its labeling I've got baby and toddlers
clothes got some some towels and baby
baby grows and things like that
and did this stuff belong - yeah it was
all junior stuff the isalus thing things
and her older brothers and sisters so
it's a good time to get it out is never
anything today you know I could have
been them it could have been me it could
have been any of us but I think it's you
know my sense was were Londoners we help
one another out after all the events
have gone on Westminster Bridge Barra
were Londoners we got up all together
but while the rest of London was showing
its generosity back at the scene of the
fire many wanted to know why
witnesses spoke about the instructions
issued to residents to stay put in their
flats and wait for rescue I said what is
your husband she said he's talking to
the emergency and I said waiting to come
out she said they tell us to stay in we
cannot come out and I said what did they
ask you to do she said they asked us to
cover the the doors so there were
firefighters inside the building
evacuated just came in trying to
evacuate the people telling them to go
but he told us to stay in but I have to
open the door and to get out other
survivors spoke of fire alarms that fail
to go off I walked down
I found the fire brigade man he's coming
to the stairs
I used the stairs to go down to see
what's happening exactly on the building
and when asked who asked him he said
there is fire on the fourth floor one of
the houses in the fourth floor the timer
run out just to get my kids and I'll
close my door because this was too much
smoke just I'll get my kids and go out
but promise there is no fire alarms
running working I don't know why the
fire brigade he didn't break the glass
to take the people to go out until when
it has been dying there and others
pointed to the new cladding that
surrounded the building it seemed to be
a factor in the rapid acceleration of
the flames that engulfed at the tower
block
I just watched that fire side of the
building like as if it was crawling up
on like as if it spray pot the way it
flew up and then I realized it was
paneling the paneling that they had been
stopped they'd be putting in the last
work they did it was the paneling they
put on the outside to make at a news
conference 12 hours after the fire had
started the emergency services insisted
it was too early to reach any
conclusions this will of course be
subject to a major investigation that's
at this moment in time we do not wish to
speculate further about the cause of the
fire or the fire spreads that is
something that will be closely looked at
in the very near future but for the
mayor of London the first politician to
visit the scene of the catastrophe there
was the early recognition that the
tragedy had the making of a serious
scandal there are genuine concerns
reasonable concerns that have been
raised through the course of the night
and it's really important that these
questions are answered I'll be demanding
answers and I can reassure you
but I'll be ensuring that we have
independence in relation to the
reassurance we need we also need to make
sure that lessons are learnt but also if
and this is a big if and Danny's right
to warn us of the importance of not
jumping to conclusions if there are you
know mistakes made we want to make sure
we learn them the fire and the response
to it was rapidly becoming a pressing
political issue an hour later Jeremy
Corbyn a lifelong campaigner on poor
quality local housing and safety issues
insisted he too would be looking for
answers when you start asking questions
is that going to include people who work
closely with the prime minister it must
include those that have been ministers
in the previous government before the
general election
and maybe are not ministers at the
present time because they had their hand
on the tiller at that time we need to
know what reports are available what
information was given and what actions
were taken these are the kind of
searching questions we must ask tomorrow
today save lives
Teresa Mays spent much of the day behind
closed doors in cross government
meetings to coordinate the response at
8:20 that evening she made her first
public statement once the scene is
secure once the recovery is complete
then an investigation will take place
into the cause of the fire and if there
are any lessons to be learned but until
then our focus must be on ensuring that
the emergency services have what they
need to continue with their harrowing
work and that help and support is being
provided to all those who have suffered
as a result of this tragedy
for many it was not enough the failure
at that stage to call for a full public
inquiry meant she'd misjudged the mood
of the nation and it was becoming clear
the fire had the potential to cause her
already fragile administration yet more
damaged mr. Corbin and other Labour MPs
have challenged the government on
statements made by Gavin Barr well now
by coincidence he's in the new chief of
staff here but he was the Housing
Minister until he lost his seat last
Thursday he last year in Parliament
promised new fire safety regulations and
labor have been claiming that those
haven't been brought in that was in
response to a fire in southeast London
actually in the constituency of Harriet
Harman and so there is some political
controversy over this dreadful tragedy
as the last flames were extinguished the
political controversy that well and
truly been ignited the victims their
families and the neighborhood became
increasingly angry how do you feel when
you look at that building what do you
mean how do I feel how do you feel like
mad look at when you can look at that
building you can tell me how you feel
and times that by a thousand B I mean
these people is much looking at building
how do I feel it's looking at the
building and knowing that I know people
who died in that building everyone every
resident every person who can conserve a
part of the community of Notting Hill
would have at least known one person in
that building
[Music]
at around 1:00 a.m. on the morning of
Wednesday the 14th of June a fire tore
through Grenville tower in West London
but tonight there are 58 deaths and it's
a death toll which is expected to rise
[Music]
36 hours after the tragedy the Prime
Minister upgraded her initial
announcement of an investigation to a
full-scale public inquiry
right now people are want answers and
it's absolutely right and that's why I
am today ordering a full public inquiry
into this disaster we need to know what
happened we need to know have an
explanation of this we owe that to the
families to the people who have lost
loved ones friends and the homes in
which they lived
and the Metropolitan Police have now
launched a criminal investigation into
the cause of the fire so how is it that
the 23-story building could be engulfed
in flames so quickly with such a huge
loss of life
Grenville tower was built in 1974 as
part of the great construction boom
carried out by local authorities to
house low-income families in 2002 the
Council passed responsibility for the
refurbishment of the tower block to a
private not-for-profit company the
Kensington and Chelsea tenant management
organization but for years the
relationship between the organization
and the tenants was poor and the
questions over fire safety were
constantly raised in 2013 there was a
massive power surge which knocked out
all the electrical devices in people's
homes up to about the 10th floor that
was when they first started raising
concerns about the safety of the
building what would happen if there was
a major fire in 2014 the local authority
embarked on a series of renovations
across the borough including Grenville
Tower the Kensington and Chelsea tenant
management organization contracted work
to a company called ride and maintenance
limited who received eight point six
million pounds for the refurbishment
another contractor was the East Sussex
based Holly facades who provided the
rain screen over clad and replacement
windows for the building the contract
worth 2.6 million and which UK based in
Halifax was contracted to work on the
smoke ventilation system during the
refurbishment project there were a lot
of problems came up and residents raised
them with the TMO and with the council I
raised them I I sent 91 concerns there
were major concerns just about the way
the project was being handled
in the months leading up to the blaze a
Tenants Association the Grenville action
group also asked questions about fire
safety in a blog in November 2016 they
stated that only a catastrophic event
will expose the ineptitude and
incompetence of our landlord and in
March 2017 we are on record as stating
that it's our belief that a serious and
catastrophic incident will be the
undoing of this mini mafia on the
Wednesday evening after the fire we
asked the head of the Management Group
about the list of concerns we do look
listen to it residents on my board we
were very concerned about these things
and we address them and get to the
bottom of that I can't really comment
what other councillors are saying at the
moment along with the police in the fire
brigade we're just trying to work out
resolve where we are at the moment and
then we'll all contribute to the
investigation to find out the causes
rather than responsive what people say
and put the tenants grievances to the
head of the council I understand the
anger I'm angry this has been the most
devastating fire I think anybody can can
remember it was the most appalling
tragedy but the renovation of a tower
will always be based on the advice the
regulatory standards the requirements to
build in fire safety and there will need
to be thorough investigation as to
whether
this refurbishment met those standards
we also paid a visit to the headquarters
of the contractors the Ryden group and
asked for an interview we spoke on the
phone and we because people the director
that statement read ride and maintenance
limited completed a partial
refurbishment of the building in the
summer of 2016 for Casey TMO on behalf
of the council which met all required
building regulations as well as fire
regulation and health and safety
standards and handover took place when
the completion notice was issued by
Royal Borough of Kensington and Chelsea
Building Control in light of the public
inquiry we cannot make any further
comment at this time so what are the
cladding provided by the subcontractors
that many eyewitnesses claimed was
responsible for the spread of the fire
Sky News obtained cladding made from the
same source as that found at Grenville
Tower it consists of aluminium layers
sandwich Inge polyethylene insulation in
the middle we took the material to a
safety testing lab capable of generating
the intense heat that was found in the
fire after two minutes the aluminium
buckles under the heat and the
insulation is exposed it now becomes
fuel for the fire
exposed it is eventually going to start
to separate the various layers and
so the cladding looks like one
explanation for the rapid spread of the
flames tower blocks are constructed to
be compartmentalized if a fire breaks
out in a kitchen for example fire doors
should keep that blaze within a flat
elements like the lift shaft are also
fire proofed and isolated to stop fire
spreading so is the fire escape the
emphasis is on giving people enough time
to escape while the fire burns cladding
though can bypass those features by it's
highly flammable insulation which can
then travel between floors and it can
also contain cavities either by design
or the fire damaging the exterior if the
flame gets in here it will shoot up as
it gets oxygen extending up to five or
ten times its length that means it can
skip up floors if the windows are open
on the floor above as many would have
been on a hot London night the flame can
spread back into the building on another
floor in 2000 a parliamentary inquiry
into cladding and fire safety had made a
number of recommendations many of these
had been included in an industry report
published eighteen months before the
blaze including we do not believe that
it should take a serious fire in which
many people are killed before all
reasonable steps are taken towards
minimizing the risks residents we spoke
to insist they raised the report with a
Tenace management organisation and say
their warnings were ignored things like
that when it happens you know if you
ignore it something bigger will happen
and he happens they've known now for
over two years that's even that
documented on the internet you know they
knew about wiring and for three things
even my friends have complained and you
know it's like they tell you they're
gonna sort it and this morning the
shocked revelation from Chancellor
Philip Hammond that the cladding may
well have been banned here in the UK
confusion about fire safety regulation
and missed warnings no wonder there's
growing anger towards authority the
child's anger was directed towards the
London Mayor Sadiq Khan in one of his
many visits to the site following the
tragedy the building now that's why it
takes some time oh no it's very sad
because you may have a friend in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and within 24 hours the sense that no
one was listening would lead to furious
protests breaking out across London
by Friday morning the blaze at Grenville
tower had finally been extinguished but
the mood in the streets around the
ruined tower block was one of growing
anger at the Prime Minister why aren't
you down here comforting people yeah you
went and saw some firemen and they're
talking about security risk security
she's a disgrace they put all the black
people and all the poor people in the
towers and this is happened the
government by now conscious that they
had been slow to respond to the public
mood dispatched their senior politicians
but the reception for the leader of the
House of Commons was one of barely
contained fury
enough is enough I've got friends in
that tower I have a right to be angry
I've got friends in it because of people
saving money
people are dying yeah well you know that
that's why it will be so important to
get to the bottom of what it's going to
take too long though isn't it it's just
going to take far too long people here
you're on the verge on the verge of some
serious anger in the streets and I am I
absolutely understand it I can see it
and I'm deeply deeply sorry on behalf of
all of my colleagues in the House of
Commons sending our greatest sympathy
in contrast the reception for Her
Majesty the Queen and Prince William was
one of respect and gratitude when they
visited the survivors Her Majesty met
the victims and listened as they shared
with her tales of trauma and suffering
going through the hall the
uncontrollable wailing of a woman whose
anguish expressed the feelings of all
those who survived
[Applause]
[Music]
Prince William himself the veteran of
many rescue operations spoke of the
trauma suffered by those caught up in
such terrible circumstances
as they left an explanation that they
had to go but a promise they would
return but later that afternoon hundreds
of protesters took to the streets of
West London for many the fire had become
a potent symbol of everything that was
wrong with the way they were governed
and now they were demanding answers they
asked for more support for the living
and for more details about their dead
everyone wants answers here we don't
know how many people have still been
unaccounted for we need answers we need
to know when things are going to happen
we want to know when people are gonna
pay for housing we need answers now
and then this angry citizens breaking
into the townhall the wealthiest borough
in Britain the police were called to
clear the building while some protesters
implored the rest to leave it was a show
of anger and defiance that continued
after the building had been cleared
inquiry promised by the Prime Minister
is going to be appointed by and laid and
appointed by somebody who's the Prime
Minister points we believe that is not
impartial there's must be an independent
inquiry an inquest into what led to this
gross tragedy the scuffles and clashes
with security guards eventually ended
but it was a sign of the volatility in
the area
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something the Prime Minister was to
witness at first hand when she paid a
visit on Friday evening
[Applause]
[Music]
as she made her way to some Clemmons
church one of the relief centers an
angry crowd surrounded her car and
shouted out shame on you later that
evening the Prime Minister revealed she
was committed to supporting the victims
with new money I think we were all when
we saw the horrific scenes of what had
happened at Grenville Tower we all were
deeply affected by that it's absolutely
horrifying and I've been hearing stories
today from people about their
experiences I've also been hearing from
the local community about the issues and
concerns that they have now the
government is making five million pounds
available for those emergency funds for
people who need just to get money to be
able to buy the normal things of
everyday life many believe the five
million pounds is too little too late
and the Prime Minister herself has
admitted that support for families was
not good enough and the political
pressure on her and her administration
continues among the many accusations
leveled against the government the most
damning is that it failed on a series of
clear warnings to improve fire safety in
tower blocks in July 2009 a serious fire
broke out in the lacan old house a 14
story tower block in Camberwell
southeast London this is a very serious
fire one of the most serious that I've
attended certainly in terms of the
number of casualties and injuries and
tragically fatalities at this insert
six people were killed 20 seriously
injured the assistant deputy coroner
investigating the blaze wrote to the
Department of Communities and Local
Government in 2013 it is recommended
that your department encourage providers
of housing in high-rise residential
buildings containing multiple domestic
premises to consider the retrofitting of
sprinkler systems and in April 2010 yet
another serious fire in a tower block in
Southampton this blaze that surely
towers saw two firefighters lose their
lives once again the coroner
investigating wrote to the Department of
Communities and Local Government with
the same recommendations social housing
providers should be encouraged to
consider the retrofitting of sprinklers
in existing high-rise buildings in
excess of 30 meters height one of the
successive housing ministers who sat on
these recommendations was Gavin Barr
wealth now Theresa Mays chief of staff
mr. Barr well had been looking into the
issue but further meetings to discuss it
had been delayed by the general election
he declined to speak to us
[Music]
this is one of many impromptu memorial
sites that have now sprung up in the
shadow of Grenville tower it's not a
space for recrimination but rather a
place for friends and families to mourn
and for total strangers to pay their
respects and express their condolences
is something that has really touched
everybody any soul should be touched by
this despite the grim news that 58
people are confirmed dead with more
fatalities expected they're still of
those who refused to give up hope
sorry so can we give you one of these
pulses okay looking for uncle numbers on
there the pops and pulses is lost if you
here will see anything just Corinne
Mazzilli and his family have not given
up on the search for their uncle who
they last heard from in a phone call at
3:00 a.m. on the morning of the fire
grim says with a lack of official
information he's turned to social media
there he's found a video of his uncle
telling a young girl not to cry while
trapped in the fire engulfed building we
recognize his voice we recognize his
voice and it seems as if he'd gone over
to hers knowing that she was there with
her kids and they probably didn't get
out just like him and in the video she
snapchatted she can see the flames and
the smoke coming up towards them from
the outside and that the child is
basically saying I'm scared I don't know
she said this makes me cry it makes me
upset I don't want to I don't want to I
don't want to see this and he says he
says to her don't worry
don't cry it's gonna be okay he was it
was great this great with great with us
when we were younger
does it bring you comfort knowing this
is it does I mean you know for me if
again this is not hundred percent but
we're pretty sure you know he's he's
rather than being scared and panicking
just like the lady was you know she can
tell from dawn of away she's get she's
panicking she's praying the child is is
quite upset but again not sort of in a
panic stage and he's just comforting the
child you know don't worry it's going to
be okay dog Brian
[Music]
other survivors have come forward with
stories of how they lost loved ones
during their escape I opened the door
black smoke came like that to our faces
I said haha that's a different thing
okay so I dropped her from her hand and
told her to do like me part of the
dressing-gown put it on my nose so to
filter it takes about four each floor at
least something like 20 minutes or
something like that you know because
it's packed and people fighting for
their life that the sixteenth floor I
looked behind me she's there okay fine
and then continued didn't look behind me
and even if I look behind me that smoke
the black smoke Walker they are lies and
so build that black smoke sometimes he
don't see clear we reached 15 floor
I look back within and for our maid
Charlotte who we first spoke to on
Wednesday morning the tragic
confirmation that five members of his
family are dead
[Music]
the story of this fire of London has
been one of tragedy and trauma
heartbreak and heroism but it's far from
over
the miserable task of identifying those
who remain in the tower will take many
months and for the victims and the
relatives the day of judgement for those
who are ultimately responsible cannot
come too soon
[Music]
you